Çeviri: Alp Eren Özalp
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Hayat bisiklete binmeye benzer
ve dengede kalmak için
mutlaka devam etmeniz gerekiyor.
Bu dengede kalmak için
3T'yi çok iyi bilmemiz gerekiyor.
Teknoloji, tarih ve toplum.
Benim de hayatındaki dönüm noktalarından
biri işte Einstein'ın dediği bu sözü oldu.
Ve baktığımız zaman dijital dünyada,
dijital değişen dünyada,
çok önemli gelişmeler oldu.
İcatlar bunların en önemlisiydi
ilk önce insanın yapamadıkları eli ile
yapamadıkları icatlar hayatımıza girdi.
Bıçak çekiç gibi.
Daha sonra yazı, pusula hayatımıza çok
farklı noktalarda bizlere eşlik etti.
Ve daha sonralarında hızlı dönen
bu dünyada hareket eden bu dünyada
bizlerle hesap makinesi,
televizyon, telefon
ve bilgisayarlar hayatımıza
girmeye başladı.
Şimdi artık hava gibi su
gibi bilgisayarsız
teknolojisiz yapamayan bir dünyadayız
ve bu dünya bizlere ne kadar hızlı
hareket etmemiz gerektiğini
ve dengede kalmamız için sürekli hareket
halinde olmamızı bizlere gösteriyor.
Sular Başı Mahallesi
Atatürk Bulvarı No: 5, 5840, Sivas PTT
Burası benim hayatımın
dönüm noktalarından birisiydi.
Neden hayatımın dönüm
noktalarından birisiydi?
1995 yılında İnternet ilk
Sivas PTT'ye gelmişti.
Ve biz iki arkadaşımla beraber sürekli
Sivas PTT'de İnternet kullanmaya giderdik.
Hiç unutmuyorum o
yıllarda iki bilgisayar vardı.
Giriyordunuz hemen soldan birinci katta
ve üstünde bir yazı vardı derdi ki:
sadece 45 dakika kullanabilirsiniz.
Biz Fatih Güneş isminde
bir arkadaşımla beraber
45 dakika birimiz bir bilgisayara birimiz
bir bilgisayarı kullanıyorduk.
Sonra birimiz kalkıyorduk
diğer bilgisayara,
birimiz kalkıyorduk diğer bilgisayara.
Bizden başka da çok fazla Sivas'ta o
PTT'yi ziyaret eden ilk
yıllarda çok fazla kimse yoktu.
Benim için başlangıç noktası olmuştu.
Bu gördüğünüz bilgisayar hayatımızda çok
önemli hepimiz belki yaşadık bunları.
Benim bilgisayarım her zaman
evimde, Sivas'tayken açıktı.
Bilgisayar kasasını
hiçbir zaman kapamadım.
Anakart nedir? Sabit disk, hard disk,
RAM’ları sürekli değiştirerek
hayatıma bir şekilde
farkındalık katmaya başladım.
Diğer tarafta gördüğünüz Sivas'ın tabii ki
İnternet ve bilgisayar
hayatımıza girdikten sonra,
Hem bunu bilgileri satacak
hem birileri bunu tamir edecek.
İlk bilgisayar mağazalarından
teknik servislerinden biridir.
Babam şimdi belki kızacak.
Bugün öğrenecek o da ama ben
bilgisayarımı çok bozarım ki
Sezai amca ile Ali abinin olan
bu bilgisayar mağazasına
bu teknik servise gidip
bilgisayar nasıl tamir ediliyor?
Bilgisayarı nasıl tamir edebiliriz?
Onu öğreneyim.
Her ay bozardım bir
şekilde her ay giderdim.
Fakat derlerdi ki Erdem
üç gün sonra dört gün sonra
biz sana bunu teslim edebiliriz.
Ama ben bugün almam lazım
derdim ki
Ali Ağabey desin ki o zaman otur
akşama kadar başında bekle
ama bu benim için
mükemmel bir şeydi o vesileyle
bilgisayar nasıl tamir ediliyor?
Bilgisayar nasıl oluşturuluyor?
Bunu öğrendim.
benim için bu bir farkındalıktı.
Bugün baktığımız zaman o bilgisayarlardan,
bu bilgisayarlara geçtik
ve elimde gördüğünüz alet
alet bir ekranı ve
klavye bağladığınız zaman,
o günkü kasası açık olan bilgisayardan
çok daha hızlı bir şekilde
şu anda çalışmakta.
Yeni bilgisayarım bu
elimde gördüğünüz alet,
Sivas'ta gazetecilik çok
önemli bir meslekti
ve yerel çok fazla gazete vardı.
Arkada gördüğünüz bu gazete,
Sivas'ın önemli gazetelerinden birisiydi,
hâlâ yayın hayatına devam ediyor.
Ama benim için en önemli özelliği,
Sivas'ın en büyük ekranlı en hızlı
çalışan bilgisayarları bu gazetedeydi.
Ondan dolayı fırsat buldukça,
Kaan Ağabey'e Mete'ye
sevgili arkadaşlarıma ziyaret eder.
Bu gazetede mizanpajına
nasıl destek oluruz?
Onlara bakmaya eşlik
etmeye gayret ederdim.
Çünkü o bilgisayarlar benim için
bir tutku demek, bir odaklanmak demek,
bir hayal demek, bir zevk
ve mutluluk demekti
ve hayatımızın bir dönemi
o gazetede hafta sonları,
akşamları vakit geçirerek geçti.
Daha sonraları bir uyanış yaşadım.
99 yılında bir gazete okumayı
çok sevdim ama
gazeteyi yere yayarak okumayı severdim.
Geniş göreyim diye.
Bir gün evde otururken,
gazeteyi geniş bir şekilde yanlış
bakarken bir ilan gördüm.
Türkport isminde Türkiye'nin
ilk İnternet portalı kurulacak.
Nedir bu internet portalı,
bir İnternet sayfasında
şehrin ihtiyaçlarını, nöbetçi eczanesi,
sineması hangi okullar var?
Bunları açıklayacak bir kent rehberi.
Başvurmayı düşündüm.
Önce ailemle paylaştım.
Bunun çok gerçekçi olmayacağını düşündüler
doğal olarak. İstanbul'da bir de.
Ama bir gazetede gördüğüm
e-maille başvuraraktan
öncelikle bir web sayfası
yarışmasına katıldım.
Bu web sayfasını yaparak yaklaşık bir
buçuk dakikada yapmıştık, o zamanlar
çok da basit bir web sayfasıydı
Kent rehberi yöneticilerinden,
İstanbul, Ankara, İzmir
biz de Sivas'ı ekledik.
Dört şehirle beraber biri
olarak ilk çalışma
hayatıma lise yıllarında
atıldım, diyebilirim.
Benim için çok özeldi. İstanbul'a
gelmişim. İstanbul'a gitmişim.
Hiç unutmuyorum, 12 saatlik bir otobüs
yolculuğu, Kılıçkaya Turizm, şimdi yok.
12 saatlik bir otobüs yolculuğuyla
İkitelli'de bir medya
plazaya gidiyorsunuz.
Sonrasında diyoruz ki
sana diyorlar ki
bilgisayar vereceğiz sen
o iki bilgisayarla,
evinden ya da nerede oturmak istiyorsan
oradan Web mastırlık yapacaksın.
Tamam diyorum ama
diyorum bu bilgisayarları
kargo ile gönderebilir misiniz?
Babam diyorum ödemesini yapar
Sonra dönüyorum Sivas'a babam diyor ki
ne oldu dedim gelecek bilgisayarlar.
Tabii böyle yapıyor.
İki gün sonra hiç unutmuyorum
evi arıyor babam
sevgili Erdem diyor, iki tane büyük koli
geldi yardım et gel bunları eve taşıyalım.
Benim için dönüm noktalarından birisi de
bu Web portalında
19 yaşında çalışmak oldu.
Daha sonra üniversite yılları.
Müziği olan ilgim
Sivas'ta yaşıyorsunuz kütüğünüz Erzincan
bir şekilde telli sazlarla
haşır neşir olmanız gerekiyor.
Arkadaşlarınız zaten
etrafınız hep o şekilde.
Sonra üniversite yıllarında Ankara'da
üniversiteleri gezmeye başladık.
Hangi üniversitelerde okuyabiliriz?
Neler yapabiliriz?
Bu arkada gördünüz Bilkent
Üniversitesi'nin konser salonu.
Uygar isminde çok
sevdiğim bir arkadaşım vardı.
Kendisi ile beraber Ankara'daki
üniversiteleri geziyoruz
Bilkent'i de gezelim dedik
üniversite tercihlerinin öncesinde.
Ve bir konservatuar
binası çok hoşumuza gitti.
Bir de ilk defa
hadi bir bakalım
Konser salonuna gittik
bir baktık bir prova var.
Bu çift katlı gördüğünüz konser salonunda.
Sonra dedik hadi şu gördüğünüz
alana yukarı tarafa oturalım.
Ama bir kalabalık var böyle
bir kitle var araya biz de oturduk.
fakat herkes bize bakıyor sağımdaki
bana bakıyor solumdaki bana bakıyor.
Uygar'a bakıyorlar falan herkesin
önünde bir defter var kitapçık var.
Ya Allah Allah dedim herhalde dedim
bizim yabancı olduğumuzu anladılar,
Uygar yani ama şey de çok güzel
tınılar da, aşağıda keman sesleri
geliyor, çello geliyor, yani
kalkmak da istemiyoruz.
Şöyle iki, iki buçuk dakika geçti
aşağıdaki orkestra şefi bize doğru döndü.
şöyle şöyle yaptı bizim bütün
yanımızdakiler ayağa kalktı koymuş.
Biz tabii orada kaldık.
Benim Bilkent macera mı orada bitti.
Ama müziğe olan ilgim
hiçbir zaman bitmedi.
Müzik çünkü bizi değiştiren, dönüştüren,
geçmişi geleceğe taşıyan her zaman
bir araç olarak hayatımızda yer aldı.
Sonraları uluslararası bir elektronik
devlet portalı kurma hayalimiz vardı.
Girişimiz vardı onu gerçekleştirdik.
Ve o portal sayesinde gene
internet ve teknoloji sayesinde
Amerika Birleşik Devletleri'nde
bir üniversiteden kabul aldık.
Fakat orada beni değiştiren diyeyim
dönüştüren çok farklı şeyler oldu,
eğitim hayatımda özellikle.
Bu arkada gördüğünüz bina,
dünyadaki en uzun ikinci kütüphane binası.
Akademik anlamda da en
yüksek akademik kütüphanesi.
Fakat burada beni ilk etkileyen
zaten dijital çağı düşünüyoruz.
Bu dijital çağda hayatımız
geçmiş bir şekilde
gençliğimiz geçmiş idame ettiriyoruz.
Burada baktığımız zaman en üst
kattan bir aşağı doğru bir
aşağı doğru inerim dedim.
İlk gün hiç unutmuyorum.
En üst kata çıktık.
Aşağı doğru iniyoruz, iniyoruz, iniyoruz
eşimle inanılmaz kitaplar var.
İnanılmaz eserler var.
Bütün kartlar boş ve okul açık yaklaşık
70-80 bin öğrencisi olan bir üniversite.
Beş üniversitenin bağlı olduğu bir yer
Bomboş aşağı katlar.
5 kata geldim. Bir baktım,
solda gördüğünüz,
ofis
dördüncü kat üçüncü kat,
ikinci kat, ilk son ilk dört kat
bu şekilde benim 45 dakika
1 saat sıra beklediğim kütüphaneydi.
Yani orada ben tekrar bir uyanışa geçtim.
Dedim ki tamam dijital çağ, iletişim,
teknoloji kütüphaneyi de eğitimi de
akademik dünyayı da değiştiriyor.
Yukarıda 24 katta bomboş.
Ama bu ilk 4 kat sıra bekliyorsunuz
aynı kitabı ulaşmak için aynı bilgiye
ulaşmak için aynı esere ulaşmak için.
Bu benim için büyük bir değişimdi.
Gene aynı üniversitede eğitime
devam ederken ilk gün.
Hocamız tanışma toplantısı
hepimize sorular sormaya başladı.
Birinci soru el kaldırıyorum hemen cevap,
ikinci soru el kaldırıyorum hemen cevap,
üçüncü soru dedim ben tamam olmuşum
yani böyle bir üniversite de
bu kadar kişi arasında her soruya
cevaplayabiliyorum, süperim.
Bir 5 dakika ara verdi, hoca.
Ondan sonra hiç unutmuyorum.
O dönemlerde de yeni yeni başlıyor.
YouTube'u açtı.
Ve bir 7 dakikalık 8 dakikalık bir video
gösterdi ve bir anda durdurdu ve dedi ki
şimdi dedi, devamını bir
sayfalık önünüzdeki kağıda
siz olsanız ne yapardınız, yazın?
Hiçbir şey yazamadım.
Bakıyorum etrafıma
herkes yazıyor, çiziyor.
Hiçbir şey yazamıyorum.
Sıfır.
Ve orada değişmem gerektiğini anladım.
Bana onu orası kattı
Çünkü ezberlemişiz.
Kitap okuyoruz yirminci sayfaya
geliyoruz beşinci sayfaya geri dönüyorum.
Ezbere gelen soru sorulduğunda
hepsine cevap verebiliyorsun.
Ama bir baktığımız zaman
yaratıcılık konusunda
bir fikir beyan etme konusunda
nasıl kendimi geliştirebilirim?
Nasıl daha iyi noktaya gelebilirim?
İşte o Değişimi de bu
eğitim döneminde anladım.
Uluslararası şirketlerdeki tecrübelerimiz,
uluslararası örgütlerdeki
hasbelkader çalışmalarımız diyeyim
ve bu eğitim uluslararası aldığımız,
hem Türkiye'de aldığımız
hem yurt dışında aldığımız eğitimler,
aslında bana bir şeyi gösterdi.
İşte bu üç diyoruz
ya teknoloji, tarih, toplum.
Nasıl bir coğrafya üzerinde,
nasıl bir zenginlik üzerinde,
yaşadığımızı bana öğretti.
Çünkü hangi farklı
milletten insanla tanışsam,
gerek eğitim dünyasında
gerek iş dünyasında,
bizim tarihimizi, bizim
kültürel zenginliğimizi,
nasıl bir toprağın üzerinde yaşadığımızı
çok iyi bildiklerini fark ettim.
Ve buna bakarken,
biraz önce de bahsettiğim
gibi Sivas'ta yaşayıp,
Erzincan kütükte olduğunuz zaman
telli çalgılarla haşır neşir oluyorsunuz.
Ama o zenginliklerden birinin de
bizim müziğimiz olduğunu fark ettim.
Bağlama ailesi dışında
burada gördüğümüz kopuzun,
bizim Asya'dan beri
kullandığımız, Asya’dan beri
bizde var olan ve şu anda da Türkiye'de
özellikle belli başlı
sanatçıların icra ettiği
bir alet olduğunu keşfettim.
Ve özellikle 2009'lu yıllardan sonra
kopuza çok fazla ilgi duymaya başladım.
Ama kopuzda benim hissettiğim
çok farklı bir şey vardı.
Kopuz deyince sadece bir icra
edilen çalgı değil, duygular vardı
İşte o, başka medeniyetteki
insanların bende uyandırdığı,
bizde uyandırdığı medeniyetimizin
kültürümüzün tarihimizin zenginliği vardı.
İsterseniz şimdi o üç teldeki,
Orta Asya’dan günümüze kadar gelen
üç telli olan bu çalgıdaki seslere bir
kulak vererek duyguları paylaşmak isteriz.
Kopuzun tellerinden anladığım benim,
birinci telinde kültür ve tarih,
ikinci telinde iyileştirme
gücü ve kibirden uzaklaştırma,
ve üçüncü telinde bir ahenk
bu gördüğünüz perdelerden
birine yanlış bastığınız zaman,
bütün ahengi bozabilirsiniz.
Ve bizim medeniyetimiz de, bizim
zenginliğimiz de işte bu ahenkten gelen
bir tarih demeyi çok önemsiyorum.
Ama buradaki duygular belki de
hepimizin birlikte yaşadığı duygular.
Öyle bir coğrafyadayız
ki şöyle düşünüyorum,
farklı illerde farklı bölgelerde yaşayıp
Aynı telden çıkan seslere duygulanan,
hüzünlenen, birbirini tanımayan
insanların yaşadığı bir coğrafyadayız.
Erkan Oğur, bilenleriniz bilir.
Kendisi bir mucit kendisi
bir icat çıkartmış, bir insan.
Baktığınız zaman Erkan Oğur perdesiz
gitarın ve kopuzun mucidi.
Erkan Oğur’la tanışmak
benim için bir hayaldi.
çünkü kendisi kopuzu tekrar Türkiye'de
tanıtan yaygınlaştıran bir değerdir.
Ve Erkan Oğur’a baktığınız zaman,
ben Erkan Oğur’dan hiçlik
ve sessizlik öğretim.
Kendisiyle birçok konserlerine gidip
kulislerde yakalamaya çalıştım.
Kendi kopuzumun akortlarını
öğrenmeye çalıştım.
çünkü kendisinin yaptığı
akort dünyada bir icat.
Ve bu hayalden bakaraktan hayalimin hiçbir
şekilde peşini bırakmamak için
Erkan Oğur’la nasıl tanışırım? Erkan
Oğur’la nasıl bu sessizliği paylaşırım?
Onun mücadelesini vermeye çalıştım.
Ve gerçekten son özellikle yıllarda
çok daha güzel bir ilişkimizle, kendisiyle
aynı sahneyi paylaşma olanağına eriştim.
Özellikle konserlerde giriş
yapmak çok özeldir.
Ve önemlidir.
Ve konserlerde biz bu girişi
özel bir şekilde yaparız.
Ve o kadar mütevazi bir insan ki
Erkan Oğur gibi hayal ettiğim birlikte
sahnede olmayı düşündüğüm insan,
İsmail Hakkı Beyle beraber bizlere
bu girişi yapma olanağı tanıdı.
İşte bu tellerden çıkan,
ahenk
kültür ve tarih
iyileştirme gücü ve kibirden uzaklaştırma
bizleri bu noktaya taşıyan en
önemli değerlerdir.
Bu değerleri yaşarken duygularımız
bizler için gerçekten çok önemli.
Sadece bir müzik aleti olarak
görmemek gerekiyor.
Bu 3T dediğimiz teknoloji,
toplum ve tarihi
Bu tellerle beraber hayatımızın
her döneminde yaşıyoruz.
Bu zenginliğimizi nasıl bir coğrafyada,
nasıl bir toprağın üzerinde,
yaşadığımızın farkında mıyız?
Teşekkür ediyorum.